Welcome students to
pharmacology. In this
lecture we'll be talking
about the mechanisms
of how therapeutic
drugs can cause toxicity
and we'll also describe
pharmacogenomics,
which is a study of how
genes affect a person's
response to drugs. Dr.
Goldstein speaking.
Please contact
me if you'd
like to talk
pharmacology.
Famously,
Paracelsus said many
hundreds of years
ago, all things are
poison, for there
is nothing without
poisonous qualities.
Only the dose permits
something not
to be poisonous.
This is a fundamental
concept that we have
been talking about
since the beginning.
Here are the
learning objectives,
mechanisms, mechanisms,
mechanisms, some
suggestions for studying,
some links if you'd
like to access
these resources
and terminology.
Absolutely essential
to have your
terminology become
second nature to you,
which only happens
by using it, using
it over and over and
over, using it in
conversation with
people who will
understand the language
of medicine. I'll
give you many
examples to illustrate
the points that I
making to show you
different mechanisms
of these various
toxicities in a
clinical context.
So in addition to
learning the terminology,
please be able to
recognize, explain
in your own words
out loud to someone
who understands the
language of medicine
to people who do
not understand the
language of medicine.
Say it in lay
terms and apply the
following concepts.
The types of adverse
drug reactions,
the risk factors and
causes, toxic effects,
harmful effects on
cells and organs,
therapeutic use and
pregnancy, harmful
effects of maternal
drug use on the
fetus and the neonate,
mechanisms and
causes of immunologic
adverse events,
pharmacogenomic
principles, and I
put stars on certain
items that I expect
you to memorize
because they
absolutely could
appear on an NYIT-COM
exam or possibly
even a board exam.
So let us begin
with basic concepts.
Risk factors are
many for adverse
drug reactions,
and they are
given here in this
simple mind map.
These, you can
recognize, are individual
patient risk factors
that can increase
their exposure to
adverse drug events.
They're classified as
common and predictable
or rare and mostly
unpredictable.
So common and
predictable. I'm sure you
know these intuitively.
An overdose or
possibly even an abrupt
dose reduction in
which the disease
problem can reappear.
Side effects. The
usual things like
dry mouth, nausea,
sleepiness, so many
drugs, all drugs
in fact, have side
effects that are
annoying, uncomfortable,
but not necessarily
serious.
Abrupt drug withdrawal.
A patient's been taking a
drug chronically
over time.
And many drugs need
to be gradually
tapered. The dose needs
to be tapered down
before the drug is
withdrawn. Otherwise,
the patient can
develop symptoms of the
original problem that
was being treated.
And these can be
large symptoms.
Secondary effects.
And the greatest
example of this is
antibiotic use that
predisposes a patient
to a superinfection,
an infection from an
organism that is not
going to be killed
by the antibiotic.
There are patients
who are resistant to
the drug effects or
paradoxical effects
can occur. So effects
that seem opposite of
what should happen,
that's paradoxical.
And of course,
drug interactions,
in red, in
larger letters.
Now the rare and mostly
unpredictable adverse
drug effects are an
exaggerated sensitivity.
A patient might
exhibit adverse drug
effects to a typical
dose that other people
tolerate really well.
or an idiosyncrasy.
This is a surprise
effect that is not
predictable and is not
attributed to the known
pharmacologic properties.
It's not related
to the mechanism of
the drug action or
even the mechanism of
the drug side effects.
Usually it's
an immunologic
reaction, so an allergy.
Allergies may be
predictable if the patients
had the allergic
reaction in the past.
They could have the
allergic reaction again
and again so that's a
predictable allergy.
And possibly these are
related at the
gene level.
The mechanisms are
frequently not known.
Adverse drug
reactions, ADRs,
are unwanted,
uncomfortable, or
dangerous effects
of the drugs.
Adverse drug events,
ADEs, are injuries
directly resulting from
the medication use.
They can be physical
harm, mental harm,
loss of function.
It's an event.
High-risk populations.
Older persons
are generally
at the top of
the list of high
risk many things.
Medication toxicity
is a major cause
of hospitalization
in older patients.
Of interest, adverse
drug events cause
approximately 1.3 million
emergency department
visits each year. This
is data from 2017.
About 350,000 of
those patients need
to be hospitalized
for further treatment.
So this is not
a small problem.
And what's really
important is that these
adverse drug events
are potentially
preventable because
they are predictable.
Okay, what do we see?
Older patients
generally have
multiple comorbidities,
so a number of
things they're
being treated for.
Polypharmacy, so
they're using multiple
drugs, and on top
of it, they're often
using OTC products,
herbal products, so
it's very important
to specifically ask
patients so they can
be put into their
history. And then a
prescribing cascade.
This happens when an
adverse drug effect
is misinterpreted
as a new medical
condition, leading to
another prescription.
Pregnant individuals,
certain drugs
may be harmful to
the fetus and the
neonate. And infants
and young children.
Infants particularly have
immature metabolic
processes,
and these generally
mature rather
quickly, but not
all of them. So
there are differences
in age-dependent
development of
organ function,
and something
very important
with pediatric
patients is the
potential for
dosing errors.
and then children will
put lots of little
lots of things in their
mouths and they can
take accidentally
take pills especially
if the medications
or if it's a solution
looks like candy or
something good to drink
more categorizations
of these various
drug toxicities So
they're typically
predictable. I've said
that three or four times
now and I will say
it many more times.
How are they
predictable? They're
based on knowledge.
Knowledge of the
mechanisms,
mechanisms, mechanisms.
Mechanisms of action,
mechanisms of
adverse effects.
Knowledge of where
they distribute to.
knowledge of the dose
response relationship
predictable based
on knowledge.
Dose dependent means
they're related to
the concentration
of drug in the body
and to the duration
of the exposure so
some drugs it's
small doses are taken
only one or two
times may not produce
the adverse effect
but taken and over
time, or in higher
drug concentrations,
we begin to see those
adverse effects.
We have them divided
in this illustration
to intended tissue,
in other words,
where is the therapeutic
effect supposed
to occur, and the
unintended tissue.
These adverse effects
can be on target,
target or off target.
On target results from
the drug interacting
with its therapeutic
target and
that target may be in
a particular tissue
or it can also be
in tissues where
we're not looking for
therapeutic effect
and that can cause
an adverse effect.
So let's look at on
target adverse effects.
The dose is too high
or there's chronic
activation or inhibition
of the effects.
Other on target effects
but in unintended
tissue is the
correct receptor but
not the right
tissue. So let's say,
well I'll give you
examples correct receptor
I did that one the
dose is too high
and a chronic activation
or inhibition of
effects both intended
and unintended
tissues now off target
it's the incorrect
receptor that's activated
or inhibited off
target in unintended
tissue is the incorrect
receptor is activated
or inhibited.
So that can
occur in the same
target tissue or
somewhere else.
Toxic effects
may be acute,
happening right
away. They may be
delayed or they
may be cumulative.
They as applying
a topical product
and getting a reaction
to that topic.
Another example of
a local reaction
is taking an oral
medication that
actually causes
stomach irritation
and ulcers. That's
a local reaction.
Systemic reactions
that occur after the
blood achieves systemic
concentrations.
Immunologic reactions or
immunogenic reactions.
Hypersensitivity,
that's allergy.
Mechanism-related immune
system upregulation.
So this is actually
a therapeutic
effect. This is
the point of the
drug to upregulate
the immune system
to attack cancer,
tumor cells.
But the upregulation
of the immune
system can also
attack our host
tissues that are
not diseased.
Photosensitivity,
it's what it sounds
like. Exposure to
sunlight. Fetal toxicity.
Exposure of the
fetus to toxic drugs.
now in terms of the
levels the cellular
level apoptosis
necrosis DNA damage
mutagenesis where
there is just a change
in the gene that can
give rise to altered
proteins carcinogenesis
mutations that
give rise to cancer
and organ toxicities
I put four here there
are more forfeit
here and these are
very common. So
liver, kidney, nerves,
and bone toxicity.
Bone marrow
toxicity, sorry.
toxicity, we think
of low levels
of blood cells.
Red blood cells, white
blood cells,
and platelets.
On the left upper,
we see an apoptotic
cell, a white blood
cell that's undergoing
apoptosis. The
important point here
is that these membrane
-covered particles
are blimbing off
of the white blood
cell as it's dying,
and because they
are membrane-covered,
they're not going
to be toxic to the
neighboring cells.
Compare that to this
necrotic cell that
is just bursting
and it's dumping its
contents into the
local environment. DNA
damage, it can be
either DNA breaks, and
that is a goal of many
chemotherapeutics,
or it could just
be changes in the
sequence of the amino
acids, and that will
give rise to a
functional, an aberrant
functional protein
or a non-functional
protein, and here are
some histo pictures.
On the left
-hand inside we
see granulomatous
hepatitis.
In the middle, it's an
interstitial nephritis.
I've marked, I've
given you these
arrows, red arrows and
stars to show what they're
referring to in the
legend underneath.
And here is a CT, a
chest CT of a patient
receiving an anti
-cancer drug that's
called erlotinib,
and this erlotinib is
actually causing this
pulmonary toxicity.
Peripheral neuropathy
is a common adverse
effect of chemotherapeutics.
Other drugs can
cause it too. You don't
have to memorize this
scheme here. It's just
pointing out different
locations on neurons
where neurotoxicity
can occur and lead to
peripheral neuropathy.
Photosensitivity,
drug-induced
photosensitivity
is categorized as
phototoxicity
or photoallergy.
So phototoxicity is
actually the drug
producing products
that can absorb
the UV radiation And
that can actually
directly cause
cellular damage that
looks like this
terrible sunburn.
And photoallergy, you
can see these welts here.
You can tell it's a
hypersensitivity
reaction.
So here's some check
your knowledge.
I suggest you
pause the video and
see if you can
remember the answers.
so for those of you
who have paused let's
come back now what
are the causes of
the common and predictable
adverse effects
what is the meaning
of on target and
off target effects
what cellular and organ
damage can occur
as a result of drug
-induced adverse effects
so for the answers
I suggest you look
back at the slides.
Let's talk about the
use of therapeutic
drugs during pregnancy.
The therapeutic
benefit of
medication use in the
expectant mother
must be weighed
against the potential
adverse effects on
fetal growth and
fetal development.
Health risks and
benefits of drug therapy
to both mother and fetus
must be considered.
The vast majority
of drugs are
not recommended
during pregnancy.
Pregnant
individuals are not
included in
clinical trials.
So the information
we gather is the use
of prescribed drugs,
of FDA-approved drugs,
in individuals who
are in a pregnancy
registry so that we can
follow the pregnancy,
follow the effect
on the fetus, follow
the effect on the
neonate. In other
words, gather data. all
prescribers have the
responsibility of
educating pregnant
patients not to
take any medications
prescription over-the
-counter or recreational
during pregnancy
consult a pharmacist
pharmacist can be very
helpful here and the
obstetrician before
taking any medication
the pregnancy and
lactation labeling
rule is really a
very convenient
very helpful way of
guiding prescribers
on the recommendations
the data
and the recommendations
for all drugs
FDA-approved drugs.
They include
information about
pregnancy during
labor and delivery,
pregnancy
including labor and
delivery, about
breastfeeding, and
about prior to
becoming pregnant.
All of these words can be
broken down into
a few ideas.
Data, data risk summary
based on the data
and management data
risk management that's
it data risk management
the great thing
about the pregnancy
and lactation labeling
rule especially
compared to the way it
was previously done,
which was with letters
A, B, C, D, and X,
is the management
recommendations based
on the data and risk.
Lactation is
the same thing.
Data,
risk, and clinical
considerations
for the fetus.
Now, reproductive
considerations
for females
and males. This
is prior to
becoming pregnant.
So there are recommendations
about pregnancy
testing before
giving drug therapy.
Should the patient be
tested prior to it?
Is it not necessary?
That sort of thing.
Certain drugs,
patients taking
certain drugs should
not become pregnant
while they're taking
those drugs. So
there's contraceptive
advice regarding
when appropriate.
And certain males
can pass on drugs
through ***** to
a female who may
become pregnant or
who is pregnant.
So that information is
also included in the
pregnancy and lactation
labeling rule.
Please have a general
sense of the utility of
this information for
the pregnant patient or
the patient intending
to become pregnant.
You don't have
to memorize these
words. Just get
the main idea.
Now, a teratogen is a
drug that exerts its
effects on target
organs at a particular
stage of fetal development
during the limited
time of organogenesis
of the target organ.
This little chart shows
the time frames of
organ development
during the embryonic
period. You don't have
to memorize this, it's
just kind of interesting
to get an idea of
when the various organs
are in development.
So that's
teratogenesis, when
it exerts its
effect at particular
stages in organogenesis.
Fetotoxicity is
basically any
injury to the
fetus at any time.
Injury to the fetus
from a substance
that enters the
maternal and placental
circulation which
may cause fetal
malformations, altered
growths, or in utero
death. So it's a
broad basket term.
Teratogenicity
we talked about,
and a teratogen
is any agent
that will cause
teratogenicity.
Now, let's not
forget the neonate.
So,
when mothers take drugs
like alcohol and opioids,
benzodiazepine,
barbiturates,
certain other drugs
chronically that can
have an effect of opiate
use, I mean opiate.
well how do I say this
that can be addictive
then chronically
the babies also take
that in and then
when they're born
there's an abrupt
withdrawal now of this drug
because they're not
receiving it in the
mother's circulation
anymore so they
can develop neonatal
abstinence syndrome.
And of course other
effects include
********* births,
low birth weight,
heart defects,
other birth defects.
The picture of neonatal
abstinence syndrome,
drug withdrawal
syndrome that follows
in utero exposure
to maternal opioids,
alcohol, benzodiazepines,
barbiturates.
And I especially
like the picture
of this poor child
who looks like
it's suffering from
this withdrawal.
So this needs to
be treated and the
neonatologist knows
how to do that.
All right, test
your knowledge.
What information is
provided in the pregnancy
and lactation labeling
rule that can be
helpful to clinicians
in educating pregnant
patients and individuals
with reproductive
potential about drug
use during pregnancy.
So I invite you
to pause the video
and have a thought
about this.
And here are the
answers. The labeling
of each drug should
include collection
of data through
pregnancy registry
data about the
potential risks of
medication during
pregnancy, the risk summary,
and clinical
considerations for
use during pregnancy
and breastfeeding.
Breastfeeding risk
data about the timing
of breastfeeding,
excretion of drug in breast
milk, and the risk
to the infants are
provided along with
clinical considerations.
Reproductive
considerations for females
and males include
pregnancy testing
recommendations before
beginning drug therapy,
contraception advice,
and information
about infertility
for males who wish
to father a child.
I forgot to include
that when I was talking
about it before,
but certainly that
is a consideration.
Drug immune system
interactions.
In other words,
hypersensitivity reactions.
A drug may act as an
antigen and elicit
a hypersensitivity
response. A drug may
interact with immune
receptors and lead
to activation of
specific immune cells.
Drugs can induce
all types of immune
-mediated
hypersensitivity or
allergic reactions
that can cause
significant morbidity
and lead to death.
and you may recall
that I mentioned in
the beginning that
these may be predictable
so we need to take
a good history about
the potential about
the person's past
hypersensitivity
reactions or they may
be unpredictable in
which case the patient
has taken it safely
before and now this
time has a
hypersensitivity reaction.
Mechanisms. Mechanisms.
Mechanisms. Haptans.
Small molecules
normally are unable
to elicit an
immune response.
They are not
immunogenic. However,
these small molecules,
either they're
drugs or the metabolites
of the drugs,
that are not reactive
normally become
immunogenic by
covalently binding to
host proteins on
cells or plasma, and
that's called hapten
carrier complex.
Now, these hapten
peptide fragments are
presented by antigen
-presenting cells to the T
-cells, hence an allergic
reaction can occur.
Biologic drugs, these
are proteins. When
you see that word,
biologic drugs,
according to the
terminology at this point,
that means they're
made out of proteins.
So protein drugs,
such as monoclonal
antibodies, there are
other types of protein
drugs, can preferentially
stimulate antibody
responses and some
T-cell responses.
So whenever we're
giving a monoclonal
antibody drug,
whether it's
the first time or
subsequent times,
the staff must
be prepared to
manage any type of
hypersensitivity
reaction that can occur.
And drug-induced
autoimmunity.
This is, in other words,
autoimmunity is when the
antibodies attack
the host cells.
So an autoimmune
phenomenon where the
patient develops
symptoms similar
to an autoimmune
disease. And lupus
-like disorder always
jumps up first.
Systemic lupus
erythematosus is an
autoimmune disorder.
and some drugs
can actually cause
a hypersensitivity
reaction that
resembles lupus.
And I mentioned
a couple more.
Most drugs are small
molecular weight
compounds with simple
chemical structures
which are not
easily recognized by
immune cells and too
small to interact
with immune
receptors with enough
strength to activate
T and B cells. That's
when we think about
hapten formation.
This is the Jalen
-Koombs classification.
You may have
received this lecture
already. If not, you
will be receiving it.
We talk about drug
therapies and allergic
reactions,
hypersensitivity reactions,
with each and every
drug. This is a
must-know concept.
I'm not going to go
over it here, but you
should learn about
this when, hopefully,
in this term.
So test your knowledge.
Small chemicals are
not easily recognized
by the immune cells
and too small to
interact with immune
receptors with enough
strength to activate T
and B cells. How do
these drugs or their drug
metabolites elicit
an allergic reaction?
Okay, say it out loud.
I'll give you a moment.
Small molecules
may induce a
hypersensitivity reaction
by covalent binding
to host proteins on
cells or in plasma
forming a hapten
carrier complex.
These haptenpeptide
fragments are presented
by antigen-presenting
cells, two T-cells,
ultimately eliciting
an allergic reaction.
Let's shift now over
to pharmacogenomics.
Pharmacogenomics
is defined as the
systematic
examination of genes,
gene products,
and variation in
gene expression
and function.
There are tools
to do this.
Pharmacogenomics
researchers evaluate
multigenic determinants
of drug response.
So you know it's
about drugs because
it's got the word
pharmaco in it,
and you know it's
about genomics because
it's got the word
genomics in it.
So this is drug
response in an
individual or
across a population.
Pharmacogenetics
is frequently used
interchangeably.
It is the effect
of a person's
genetic factors on
that person's
response to the drugs.
And precision,
or personalized
medicine, this is
becoming a very
important aspect
of clinical care.
So, in other words,
being able to select
the appropriate
drug for the right
patient and to avoid
drugs that would
cause an adverse
effect in a patient and
based on their
pharmacogenetic makeup.
And this little
figure shows all the
different ways that
we can think about it.
Single nucleotide
polymorphism simply means
that there is a change
in the sequence.
So whereas here
is a sequence,
there's one change
in each of these
other individuals,
and that can cause
an important
variation that will
affect their response
to drug therapy.
most of these variants
don't affect how
people respond to a
drug but some do and
there are screening
tests to help us
identify the patients
who might be at risk
how do we look at these
poor metabolizers,
intermediate
metabolizers, extensive
metabolizers, ultra
-rapid metabolizers.
So poor metabolizers
means that they're not
metabolizing as well
as other people and
if a drug is not
being metabolized then
there will be higher
blood levels and higher
blood levels for a
given dose can mean an
increased risk of
adverse drug effects,
adverse drug events. So
how does this happen?
Poor metabolizers
have two alleles
encoding a non
-functional protein.
So either the so
likely the protein
is completely
absent or it
just is not
functioning properly.
Intermediate
metabolizers have one
functional allele
and they may be
phenotypically similar.
In other words,
they do metabolize
at the same rate as
the vast majority
of the population.
Extensive
metabolizers have two
functional genes,
so two alleles
are supposed to
be functioning.
So this would be when
everything's
working fine.
This one is
one allele, but
phenotypically
it's working fine.
And ultra-rapid
metabolizers.
So a patient who is an
ultra-rapid metabolizer
metabolizes at a much
increased rate. And
what happens when the
rate of metabolism
of a drug is very much
increased well the
blood levels are
very much reduced and
therefore it will be
less likely to have a
therapeutic effect so
very high enzymatic
activity and this is
occasionally due to gene
duplication there's
considerable research
going on in
pharmacogenomics to identify
these different
phenotypes, genotypes and
phenotypes. Now,
polymorphisms in genes
for transporters and
major histocompatibility
complex are also
potential causes for
differences in
pharmacokinetic properties.
These charts here
demonstrate the
differences in
population frequency
for the various types
of metabolizers.
We have poor
metabolizers here,
ultra-rapid metabolizers
here, so that's
either end of the
population. um ultra
ultra rapid
metabolizers this is an
indication of the
concentration versus
time curve and so
the peak is much
lower and the clearance
is much more rapid
poor metabolizers
just the opposite.
Poor metabolizers
for a given dose,
the concentration
can go up,
up, up, up, up
into toxicity land.
Ultra-rapid metabolizers
may be below the
therapeutic minimum
concentration. These
pie charts show the
relative activity of
the different enzymes,
or I should say
the relative metabolizing
capability of
the different
enzymes on drugs and
everything else that
goes into our bodies.
CYP3A4 mentioned
before nearly 50%.
And I'll be talking about
CYP1A2 in terms
of smoking.
It's a small
sliver, but it
is therapeutically
important.
And CYP2D6 has been
widely studied for poor
metabolizers and ultra
-rapid metabolizers.
And so forth.
Glucuronotransferase
is here,
the majority of drugs
that are metabolized
by phase 2 reaction
go through the UGTs,
NAT2 is sticking out
here because there
are some very
important interactions
that can occur
with, I should say
adverse events that
can occur with poor
metabolizers, and so on.
This is just to give
you a visual of the
activity of these
various enzymes.
So I put a star
on some of these
well, a lot of these
enzymes that we're going
to be talking about.
I am asking students
to know the mechanisms
mechanisms mechanisms
these are drugs here
that you may not know
the names of I'm not
asking you to memorize
the names at the
moment you need to know
the mechanisms so I
may use a drug name on
an exam item but it's
the mechanism that
you should be able to
recognize whether I use
a drug name hydralazine
or whether I use a
drug name drug A.
So NAT2, I mentioned
that one before,
N-acetyltransferase
type 2
for the poor
metabolizers.
There are three
drugs that really
are known for producing
adverse effects
because of the
poor metabolism
of NAT2, poor
metabolizer phenotype.
So what happens?
Lupus-like syndrome.
I mentioned that
one before. It can
cause this autoimmune
-like reaction.
Liver toxicity.
We'll be talking over
and over and over
about the effect of
these drugs on heart
function. So QTC
interval prolongation.
We're where it's
lengthened. And when
that gets lengthened,
this QT interval,
then we can get
something called
ventricular arrhythmia
or trossade de point.
I have a picture of that.
CYP2D6, I mentioned
also that there has
been a great amount
of studies on CYP2D6,
Metabolic SNPs and
pharmacogenomics.
Codeine, I'm sure
you know codeine.
You don't have to
memorize that one.
You already know
it. But what's
happening with
codeine, we're thinking
about ultra-rapid
metabolizers. Now
shift your thinking
for a moment.
Your thinking cap, shift
it over on your head.
codeine gets metabolized
to morphine I'm
sure you've heard of
morphine morphine is
very potent it's a
very potent opiate mu
opioid receptor agonist
so in people who are
ultra rapid metabolizers
of CYP2D6 who are
given codeine can
produce more morphine
because the rate of
metabolism of that codeine
is much more rapid.
It is therefore
producing more morphine
and more morphine will
therefore go into the
systemic circulation
and that can cause
toxicity. And And what
toxicity do we worry
about with opioids?
Respiratory depression,
which can lead to death.
And this is particularly
problematic in children,
especially young
children and
infants. Now,
codeine and morphine,
let's talk about
codeine, codeine gets
excreted in breast
milk, so the nursing
infant takes in the
codeine, and if they
happen to be a CYP2D6
ultra-rapid metabolizer
and make increased
levels of morphine,
that can lead to
respiratory depression in
the infant and that
can lead to death and
this actually is a
documented adverse effect
and then there are
lots of drugs that are
metabolized by cyp2d6
so if it's a drug that
just is metabolized
it's a substrate it's
not converted into
something active then
the levels of the drug
will be reduced for
ultra-rapid metabolizers
and increased for
poor metabolizers.
That's the concept.
Does the drug get
converted to an active
metabolite that will
have increased levels in
the ultra-rapid
metabolizer but decreased
levels in the poor
metabolizer? is the drug
just a substrate and
its own metabolism
and its own blood
levels will be affected.
So that's the way
to think about
the ultra-rapid and
poor metabolizers
with CYP2D6 and
everything else.
Now I mentioned the
phase 2 UGT. UGT, so
UGT1A1 is a widely
involved isoenzyme,
bilirubin is
metabolized, unconjugated
bilirubin is conjugated
and made water
-soluble by the
glucuronide metabolite.
So if this is
under-functioning,
then bilirubin
will be conjugated
to a lower degree.
So this doesn't
usually matter,
except in infants.
Here we go with
the infants again.
Infants have under
-functioning UGT to begin
with, because it's
just not mature yet.
and bilirubin can
increase, unconjugated
bilirubin can increase
in blood, in the blood.
Now there are certain
drugs also that require
functioning UGT1A1
and when we get to
those drugs I'll ask
you to remember them.
The takeaway is
with bilirubin
which is a
physiologic product
Unconjugated bilirubin
can accumulate in
the blood, can cause
jaundice in the
neonate, and in
people who have under
-functioning UGT1A1 or
inhibited by another
drug, it can cause
jaundice in the adult.
Increased toxicity
of certain
cancer chemotherapeutics.
I'll talk
about that when
we get there.
this is the butterfly
rash of the lupus
lupus autoimmune
disease and lupus-like
syndrome here we have
a normal EKG with
a normal QT interval
Q Q is right here
T is right here,
and in this lower
figure the QT interval
is much prolonged.
This can be a
congenital problem and
patients don't usually
know they have it.
And if we use a
drug that's going
to prolong that
QT interval that
can lead to
the ventricular
fibrillation. Here's
Gilbert syndrome.
This is under
-functioning UGT1A1.
G6PD deficiency has
a star on it. This
is very important
because patients with
G6PD deficiency who
are given oxidizing
drugs can develop
hemolytic anemia.
That's the
takeaway there.
Heme synthesis,
we have when
drugs will induce
enzymes in that heme
synthesis pathway,
patients can
develop porphyria.
Patients who have that
potential can develop it.
Rhianodyne receptor,
malignant hyperthermia,
we'll talk
about that when we
get to those drugs.
BKORC1, we're
going to talk about
from now until
forever probably
warfarin, but
we'll get into that
when we get to the
anticoagulants.
Here's the G6PD pathway.
Glucose 6-phosphate
dehydrogenase or
dehydrogenase is essential
for forming NADPH,
which is essential
for reduction to of
the glutathione to the
reduced form. And
glutathione is essential
for inactivating
oxidative metabolites.
And ADPH is also
important for
conversion of methemoglobin
to the regular
hemoglobin that
can bind oxygen.
G6PD, we have some
examples here.
This is a bite cell.
I don't know if you
can see it. It looks
like a bite that's
taken right out of
the red blood cell.
and blister cells.
It looks like
this blister is
forming right on
the edge of the
red blood cell.
So what's happening
here is the membrane
of the red blood
cell has been
weakened by these
oxidative agents that
accumulate in
there because they
haven't been detoxified
by glutathione.
This is a
picture of heme.
So I talked about the
heme synthesis pathway.
Here's some
cutaneous lesions
in a patient
with porphyria.
And here's acute
photosensitivity
reaction in a 10
-year-old boy with
erythropoietic
protoporphyria.
We talked about malignant
hyperthermia and
the ryanodine
receptor, and here's
the vitamin K.
So those, I'm not asking
you to memorize them
now, but when we get
to them, at least
you'll know that you
heard about it somewhere.
Long QT syndrome,
congenital or acquired.
Drugs can cause it.
Serious and unpredictable
ventricular arrhythmia.
So serious,
people can die.
Several, and then let's
move to HLA. There
are several HLA
alleles that have been
associated with an increased
risk of drug-induced
life-threatening
hypersensitivity
reactions. I will be
talking about those a lot
when we get to the
drugs that are involved.
We have the capability
now of screening
patients for various
HLA subtypes so
that we can predict
whether or not a
patient can take
the drug safely. And
this is just a
picture of what's
going on with the
long QT syndrome.
Here is a picture
of an EKG tracing
demonstrating
torsade de plant.
Clearly, this
is not normal.
And it is a
ventricular arrhythmia.
We have a picture
here of a patient
who is positive
for HLA-B5701.
and is highly likely
to have an allergic
reaction to abacavir,
which is an HIV drug.
So that person should
not get that drug.
Well, I keep talking
about adverse
reactions. So if a
patient is at risk
for a serious
adverse reaction and
absolutely needs the
drug, does that mean
the patient can't
get the drug? No.
There are strategies
for mitigating
the effects so that
a patient who really,
really must have
a drug can have
that drug. So some
strategies for reducing
the risk of adverse
drug events.
Right drug, right
patient, right dose,
right route, right time.
We need to know
how to discontinue
medications carefully.
We need to know
how to initiate
medications carefully.
We should prescribe
new medications
sparingly. Don't just
give medications because
the book says it'll
help doesn't so.
They should be
used appropriately.
Reducing the number of
prescribers, patients
who go to five or six
or seven different
prescribers of medications,
can get overlap,
can get more drugs
than they need, can
get drugs that are
interacting with each
other, and not all
drugs were are going to
appear on your electronic
medical records.
So you have to take a
very careful history.
frequent reconciling
of medications go
through what the patient
is taking educating
prescribers and
educating patients
knowledge is the
best strategy
test your knowledge
what is the
aim of pharmacogenomics
research,
pharmacogenomics
research.
Precision medicine,
pharmacogenomic
information identifying
novel genes and gene
variants may predict
efficacy and safety
or toxicity in the
individual patient.
This information may
be included in the
labeling of specific
drugs. So it's a matter
of look it up in
the drug monograph.
It's easy to look up.
You'll have access to
that easily. You can
have an app on your
phone where you work
in the hospital or
in the practitioner's
office may have access
to an electronic file.
So look it up.
When you see labeling,
that means you
can look it up in
the monograph. So,
in summary, adverse
drug reactions
and adverse drug events
from overdose,
dose reductions,
above the straw of
a drug, resistance
to therapy,
paradoxical effects,
and drug disease,
drug-drug, drug
-supplement, drug
-food interactions.
Effects may range from
relatively benign,
and that's most
frequent, fortunately,
to serious, causing
significant morbidity
or death. It may
be acute, delayed,
or chronic.
These adverse drug
reactions and events
can result from overdose,
dose reductions,
abrupt withdrawal
of a drug,
resistance to
therapy, paradoxical
effects, drug
interactions.
Drug-induced
deleterious effects
to cells and organs
can be caused
by the parent drug,
a toxic metabolite,
or reactive
oxygen species.
Small chemicals
may form haptin
protein complexes
that activate the
immune system
against the complex.
Some drugs can
directly activate a
hypersensitivity reaction
in sensitive individuals.
Mechanisms include on
-target in the intended
or the unintended
tissue, and off-target,
again in the intended
or unintended tissue.
Drugs taken by the
pregnant individual can
cause teratogenicity
or other fetotoxicity.
Neonates can
manifest abstinence
syndrome resulting from
maternal use of
addictive drugs.
Other effects on neonate
include *********
births and low
birth weight. The
pregnancy and lactation
labeling rule helps
prescribers communicate
the risks of
pharmacologic treatment
to pregnant and
breastfeeding patients,
and preconception
advice to females of
reproductive potential
and males who wish
to father a child.
Polymorphisms in
metabolic enzymes are
thought to underlie
individual differences
in the rate at which
drugs are metabolized.
The categories are
poor, intermediate,
extensive, and ultra
-rapid metabolizers.
Genetic variants
in transporters,
drug targets,
and variant HLA
alleles may also
relate to an
individual's response
to drug therapy.
Pharmacogenomics research
is the systematic
examination of genes,
gene products, and
variation in gene
expression and function,
using tools for surveying
the entire genome.
Pharmacogenomics
researchers evaluate
multigenetic determinants
that may predict drug
response, efficacy and
safety, or drug toxicity
in an individual or
across a population.
An aim of pharmacogenomics
research is to
guide decisions on
prevention, diagnosis, and
disease management
strategies using the
individual's clinical
and genetic information.
This information may
be included in the
labeling of specific
drugs, which may
help clinicians
select the drugs and
doses best suited
for the individual
patient based on their
individual genes.
Precision medicine is
an approach to tailoring
disease prevention
and treatment that
accounts for differences
in patients' genes,
lifestyles, and
environment.
Right drug, right
patient, right dose,
right route,
right time.
And that concludes
this lecture on drug
toxicities, mechanisms,
and pharmacogenomics.